[Music]
Raja I am so excited to be here with you
today thank you for joining me thank you
so much for having me I'm just so
excited to be here as well of course so
I want to start tell me about what
invisa Ware does of course so invisa
creates jewelry and accessories with
safety technology hidden inside like
this necklace I'm wearing there's a
button thank you so much nobody ever
suspected it's a safety device but if
you click this backside two times it
will immediately Alert five emergency
contacts to let them know you're in an
emergency and need help and it can also
optionally contact
911 wow what was the inspiration for you
for starting this company oh my gosh it
was so crazy never in a million years
did I ever think I would start a company
I actually was only 21 years old at the
time I was in college when I had a scary
situation I was at an event with some
friends I didn't want to inconvenience
anyone so I said my goodbyes and I
started walking back to my car as I was
about halfway between where the car is
and the event is an SUV full of guys
drove by they rolled down the window and
started yelling super inappropriate
comments the car stops and one of the
four guys starts to get out oh my God I
ended up running as quickly as I could
got to my car safely and thankfully I
wasn't hurt that night but for the next
hour and a half I was shaking
uncontrollably cuz all I could think
about is I could have been that new
story I started looking for safety
devices to buy to protect myself and the
women I care about but everything was a
big ugly panic button so it blew my mind
I was like how is nobody creating them
in
jewelry how did you feel making that
jump to take it from like an idea in
your head then to actually going and
being an entrepreneur creating the
product so I never really imagined it
would become what it is today today it
actually originally started as a class
project so I was doing my senior year
Capstone at the University of
Massachusetts LEL and I told my best
friend his name is Ry I said why don't
we create safety devices for a project
and then at the end of this we can have
them for ourselves and our loved ones
studies show one out of every five women
is sexually assaulted at some point in
her lifetime This is highly unacceptable
and needs to change so we both graduated
and we decided to decline some
prestigious job opportunities I actually
turned down an opportunity with Google I
always joke I'm like don't tell your
parents you're declining a job with
Google you're going to think you lost
your
[Music]
mind so talk to me about the scale of
your business how has your sales growth
been how many customers do you have it's
been incredible we actually have sold
over a 100,000 devices and we've Sur
passed over $15 million in Revenue which
has been such a huge milestone for
us as a woman going into a
male-dominated VC field and trying to
pitch this female Centric product how
was that for you and was it hard to to
convince people to take a chance on you
it definitely was not easy we sadly got
so many disgusting comments while we
were raising money I had one investor
look me dead in the eyes and say that he
doesn't think women care about their
safety after I specifically told him the
horrific statistics we actually had a
really horrible story happen where we
were doing a friendly shark tank pitch
competition in the entire panel four
were men one was a woman the woman
started by saying that she loves the
product wishes she had one when she was
in college the next guy looked at me and
said that his wife never ever complained
about her safety and that because of
that he doesn't think there's a need for
this
product the next judge decided to take
the cake so I started the company with a
male co-founder he's my best friend and
he looks at me and asks if I had ever
been intimate with my co-founder that's
completely inov you believe that I was
appalled one last question for you when
you were younger what would you tell
yourself the day before you launched
your company that you wish you knew now
I think the biggest advice would be to
believe in yourself so many people will
tell you all of the reasons that you
could fail I can't tell you the number
of people who thought Ray and I were out
of our minds to decline all of these
prestigious job opportunities people
would say things like nine out of 10
businesses fail and all I could think
about is well who says we're not going
to be the one out of 10 if you don't
build your dreams someone else is going
to hire you to build
[Music]
theirs
oh